what up space fam golson here from anime
uproar here to discuss the latest
developments in the one punch man story
and it just doesn't get more hype than
this if you're a fan of one punch man
not only do we have what has to be a god
level threat present
and what may end up being the final
villain of one punch man blast also
appears
he meets saitama and he shows off his
powers
he does not disappoint so make sure to
stay tuned for this one if you do enjoy
seeing these one punch man videos on the
channel and want to keep them coming the
best thing you could do
is one punch that like button i'm
serious absolutely destroy it
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select
all or you will miss future one punch
man videos and while you wait for the
next chapter
to drop feel free to check out my
growing one punch man playlist where
you'll find videos about all s-class
heroes
all dragon and god level monsters and
much more link to that is in the
description now without further ado
let's jump into it
manga spoilers and all so the cover page
we get
is interesting it looks like alternate
dimensions of the same place suggesting
there is our normal human world and
an underbelly demonic world and they are
both connected by this black
cube in the cover story it's fascinating
stuff and i think we can assume that the
god creature mentioned before by
homeless emperor who grants people
insane powers
is from this alternate dimension but can
cross over
in certain ways including with the help
of these cubes
we saw what appeared to be a tear in the
fabric of time and space at the end of
the last
chapter where we saw what must be this
creature called god
he was huge and in the fetal position
and on the other side of this seemingly
god level threat in his world
there's saitama flashy flash and the
monster there with from their
perspective they can't see anything
in the hole it's pitch black they ask
the monster to
light it up and it's hilarious how she
goes from
x-ray to thermostat to recessed light
mode
she may not be a strong monster but
she's definitely a versatile one and i
love seeing her dynamic with saitama in
flash
still though no matter what function she
uses they can't see anything through the
dark hole
then they hear the god creature speak to
them remarking on how
having three visitors at the same time
is very
unusual if this being could give
homeless emperor such a power upgrade
imagine what kind of boost he could
potentially give flashy flash or saitama
although to be fair saitama obviously
doesn't need any boosts
it is interesting to think about how
saitama may face this god level threat
if he can't physically punch it i can't
wait to learn more
about this being and how saitama will go
about fighting him
anyway the god creature tells them to
put their hands on the cube
just like we saw on the cover page and
apparently this cube will let him decide
if they are worthy of gaining more power
after they make a fervent wish flashy
flash concludes that he must be
communicating telepathically with them
since there's no sound and saitama
doesn't know what's going on as always
he thinks it might be the monster king
aka orochi but really this dude is more
like a monster god
clearly way more powerful than orochi as
he can create
insanely powerful villains from normal
humans on his own
and that's not even getting into what
must be his own insane power
still all the same saitama wants the god
creature to show himself
so he can punch him then as if this
wasn't incredibly interesting already
something teleports into their area and
it is none
other than blast the number one hero
this part was not in the webcomic and
gives us
mind-blowing information that we never
knew before
about the legend blast blast mentions he
made it in time
and we see the back of his boots and he
even has his name on them
that's a sweet touch and so are his
shades as an anime avatar who wears
shades all the time
i respect blast all the more he looks
very cool
and also like he's seen tough battles he
has a huge scar
across his face but he nevertheless
gives off such a confident aura
this is the moment of truth how will
blast mesh with saitama will saitama
make him seem like yamcha by comparison
let's find out by the way how cool do
you have to be to wear sunglasses
underground
the answer very cool blast says with his
shades down
that they haven't accepted the cube deal
yet right
and it's so cool to see blast's eyes
without his upper face being completely
in shadows i gotta say
saitama is clueless wondering if this
guy is a hero
even though he has blast on his uniform
in multiple places
saitama calls him an old man but damn he
is still cool af
despite being old blast explains that
the cube
is a transmitter touching it which they
seem to have accidentally done
distorts space and allows for
communication with him
the god creature blast is clearly well
aware of this being
his hobby all this time has been
traveling around and collecting the
cubes which is great to finally find out
blast hasn't been doing pointless stuff
he's actually been working to thwart the
creature who may end up being the final
villain in one punch man or at least
a very powerful one by doing so blast
probably prevented many other homeless
emperor-like transformations
from coming about and to hype up blast
even more
this god creature knows blast by name
and seems irritated that he's in the way
again
faced with this powerful being blast
seems completely unfazed
and uses what looks like spatial magic
from black clover to transport the cube
somewhere else
so it seems i can teleport across space
and maybe even time
and teleport other objects as well with
a cool super power that we haven't
really seen before in one punch man
and i wonder how much he could
potentially travel through time
because he was able to teleport here
even though time is being distorted
we'll find out more later but damn this
dude was so
worth the wait flashy flash is shocked
at its blast but saitama is unimpressed
as per usual
there's a great moment where flashy
flash wants to test blast to make sure
it is in fact the real
number one hero of the world he goes
maximum speed
this guy who's been said to be the
fastest of all s-class heroes
and blast effortlessly dodges him and
appears behind him without breaking a
sweat
proving that blast has to be faster than
flashy flash
it's hype because clearly blast wasn't
all talk he is clearly not a joke
character like king and his older age
clearly hasn't slowed him down much the
dude makes flashy flash sweat all over
without even trying he's definitely
lived up to the hype blast mentions the
discrepancy of time in this space
commenting that it is flowing slower so
he needs to get them out of here
i really like this added dimension of
time rather than it just being a space
thing blast singles out the monster with
them and mentions that it doesn't look
like she's their prisoner
making the monster sweat through just a
stare obviously saitama himself isn't
really phased by blast
but the other two are definitely
affected by his presence
even the god creature was which says a
lot about blast
we get a great moment where it seems
like saitama is going to turn
on the monster too but then he just
loosens things up by mentioning that the
female monster is very useful
since she's been their guide and
flashlight i'm really going to miss this
monster when we part ways with her
blast is cool with it he's clearly not
the kind of guy who would kill any
monster he sees
he's chill enough to go along with this
weird friendship
and save the monster too he uses his
fists to create an infinity sign
and creates a teleporting orb around
them all
notably he does tell our guys to send
his regards to sich
and tatsumaki and that's a nice touch
because we know how much tatsumaki was
influenced by blast and looks up to him
nice to see that he's not a
self-absorbed jerk who doesn't pay
attention to other people despite being
the number
one hero he even knew flashy flash by
name this guy definitely epitomizes what
it means to be a cool hero
in the meantime we jump to the surface
and child
emperor feels like he's not fit to lead
because he left
silverfang and demon cyborg off his team
he thinks zombie man should lead
since he's a better judge of character
but sweet mask disagrees
saying they can't have a pseudo monster
like zombie man
being the leader of a team of heroes
again you can count on sweet masks to be
all about appearances
rather than merit he says that their
leader has to be the ideal human
and i gotta say after seeing blast he
would be the perfect leader but he's
like batman too busy doing his own cool
thing to actually be their leader
while child emperor is upset that zombie
man was called a monster
zombie man is cool with it he praises
child emperor for making an effort to
understand
others and he points out that he can
improve his judgment of character
now that he knows he needs to he also
says we're all human
after all this could be taken literally
but this series also raises the question
of what does being human mean
and what does being a monster mean the
line is never that clear-cut
sometimes monsters might not be so bad
and humans can be horrible or
in terms of strength you gotta admit
that saitama's the biggest monster
and he can scare any real monster who
sees what he's capable of
garo is another great example of a
blurring of this line between humans and
monsters since he's a human
who's referred to as a human monster can
you be a monster
and a hero or a human and a monster
these are questions that one punch man
wants us to consider while we also laugh
at all the hilarious moments that ensue
along the way
obviously our female monster who's
accompanying saitama
is not so bad she's more comedic than
evil i'd argue
but back to the story where zombie man
pushes child
emperor out of the way and saves him
from an attack the damage he takes is
insane
way too insane to show on youtube but
he's zombie man so if anyone can take
that damage
and live it's him the attack was the
work of homeless emperor who has one of
the
funniest backstories of any villain and
his name is pretty funny too
pretty much everything about him is
hilarious we just dealt with the god
creature recently and now we're dealing
with someone who got their powers
upgraded because of him
in the meantime tatsumaki launches a
giant drill she created with her psychic
powers
and seemingly kills what remained of
orochi's body the drill keeps going
leading underground to some sort of
ancient temple we'll see what this ends
up meaning as we go forward but it
definitely seems to be a temple made to
offer sacrifices to a god
through caveman-esque paintings you see
figures
presenting offerings to a monster-like
being in the air
it may be an old reference to the god
creature perhaps
who has always been interfering with the
real world i can't wait to find out more
but without a doubt the highlight of
this chapter was the myth
the man the legend himself blast his
presence blew me away especially because
he didn't show up like this in the
webcomic
so this is bran spanking new information
about his powers and personality
and it was great i know i keep saying
this but it's significant that after all
the hype he did not disappoint he was
very very cool and despite coming face
to face with saitama he did not seem any
less cool
afterwards he actually helped saitama
escape from the slowed down time bubble
they were in
and how cool is it that the god creature
knows him by name it looks like blast
has been devoting himself to the
ultimate villain
and i can't wait to see what happens
between them and how saitama will fit
into the mix
i still have no doubt that saitama is
stronger than blast because that's just
the kind of
series this is but i wonder what will
happen if this god creature is a kind of
opponent you can't just
punch what will saitama do clearly after
all this time
all blasts could do is slow down the god
creature who nonetheless
still managed to lend some of its
monstrous power to people like homeless
emperor
blast despite how undeniably cool and
powerful he is didn't manage to actually
beat this being once and for all
if doing so is even possible perhaps at
some point this god creature will take
on a physical form in saitama's
dimension
and that will be the moment of truth but
for now that is it for this one
if you did enjoy this chapter review and
want to keep them coming channel your
inner blast
and destroy that like button we all know
that the chad lad blast would want it
that way
if you haven't joined the space fan by
subscribing and this is crucial
hit that notification bell and select
all or you will miss future one punch
man videos and while you wait for the
next exciting chapter to drop
feel free to check out my growing one
punch man playlist where i got videos on
all s-class heroes
all dragon and god level monsters and
much more
link to that is in the description and i
especially want to thank the patron
squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who helped make videos like this
one possible first and foremost i want
to thank the patron of legend the one
acknowledged by lord tuigo himself and
the most donated champion of the world
alpha sigma and are the one tier patrons
the ones who stand atop
all clans ingrata the world acquire
respect pate hepa dr cortman rythian
emperor taku spidey life tinel big
buddhist and tungsten tarkis and are pro
heroes here patrons the one and only
gilgamesh
steelers angel crews anatoly kazowski
joel stanton very gucci jessica kayla
fond ruthu and they aura alicia actor
bonnie parks hinokami and water the red
haired raven florian joanne garcia
jack watches anime fat boy games deadly
saint matthew cruz anthony schreiber
hijinks and mr waffles thank you all so
much
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these
amazing epic people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life
and of course dank memes so check out
patreon.com
anime up for link in the description if
you're interested you can also join the
youtube channel by clicking that blue
join button next to the subscribe button
which you've hopefully already destroyed
so yeah you can support more content
that way if you prefer and whichever way
you choose to support us
you can get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]